oui
depuis que je suis toute petite je pense
qu'à danser
si on s'en fout ensemble ce soir à bail
quoi tu deviendras la meilleure de
toutes les danseuses et moi le plus
grand important
vous êtes là grâce à votre ténacité et
votre talent
j'avais tout ce travail études sauf vous
chaque jour l'une d'entre vous sera
éliminé clinique versait sa technique
est parfaite
demain matin entraînement à ce que 5
heures du matin
y aller alors je leur ai jamais ce rôle
si tu auras fois dans le chlore quelque
chose qu'elle n'aura jamais la passion
garçons et les beaux golfs
et dès que je vais devenir une étoile
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit mais les
trois temps
il faut jamais renoncer à ses ray ban
je trouve que que tu es génial tu fais
quoi là euh je m'étire tu vois regarde
ça y est coué
depuis que je suis toute petite pause
qu'à nancy si on s'enfuit ensemble ce
soir puis deviendra la meilleure de
toutes les danseuses et moi je
deviendrai le plus grands inventeurs
as tu as un plan un plan infaillible
bail 3
bienvenue à paris princesse c'est quand
la dernière fois que tu te laver les
dents
ça y est je suis danseuse à l'opéra
enfin je suis élève pendant temps
vous êtes là grâce à votre ténacité et
votre talent sauf vous
les demain nous commencerons les
auditions chaque jour l'une d'entre vous
sera éliminé tu n'as qu'une adversaire
camille cette technique est parfaite en
du lait et le mot perdre ne fait pas
partie de son vocabulaire demain matin
entraînement à 5 heures 5 heures du
matin je suis mes toiles alors que toi
tu ne brisera jamais
tu dois apprendre à maîtriser
convertissent à
alors je n'aurais jamais ce rôle si tu
auras tu as dans le coeur quelque chose
qu'elle n'aura jamais la passion
d'un garçon il est beau gosse
et dis que je vais devenir une étoile
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit
ans avec ton coeur
haha tu fais de la danse ou du kung fu
tu es tellement drôle
une offre ici une école de danse l'opéra
de paris
je sais que tu rêve de devenir danseuse
mais les rênes ne serait lui ce pas ce
soir on s'échappe tu deviendras une
grande étoile a pris moi je reviendrai
le plus grand donateur du tout les
droits
un plan un plan infaillible
voici mes ailes de poulet ressemblant
mais t'es bête ou quoi
des poulets ça ne brûle pas bien sûr que
si
il faut jamais renoncer à ses rêves